you're watching screen junkies central
today's episode is brought to you by
t-mobile
the uncarrier hello san diego spree
junkie central in the house I'm Andy
signor i'm hector navarro and i have my
friend hector the far because we're
about to do some amazing Walking Dead
talking talk we're talking dead really
I'm so excited yes I can't create our
own Walking Dead after show talking
about it and now we have one of the
major guys behind the man behind the
curtain listen here right over there
behind that curtain I can't wait to
bring can we just bring them out let's
just do it guys hear it guys for great
Wow hi guys is this great do you want to
come out this all the time these are the
smartest people in San Diego right now
they are they're the least sweaty and
the happiest right now so I got it I
want to just get off right away like we
know your effects and it's amazing and I
we're going to go through a lot of this
but what I'm most impressed was you now
become like the best director for the
show like you how cool is that it must
be so fun for you to now be really like
the go-to for all their biggest shows
like tell me about that experience of
the going from one to the other I'll
tell you the first the first time I
directed it was season two it was the
episode where Dale gets killed and I had
dinner with Frank Darabont and he said
listen you're ready do you want a zombie
heavy episode or a zombie light episode
I knew was a trick question
I'm like that's kind of a trick question
it's a little sorry guys but I
said a zombie light episode so I had one
Walker in the entire episode but it was
the most dramatic yeah it was literally
12 Angry Men
where Dale is pleading for the life of
this prisoner and I watched a whole
bunch of movies before I had shot the
episode like a watch Miller's cross
let's see what John Turturro on his
knees so I did all this kind of cool
homework for it and had dinner with chef
Tom on and I drew like little schematics
and everything I was so prepared that
the camera operators were like look how
cute you are with your little drawings I
was like give it isn't that what I'm
supposed to do and I'll never forget
editing the episode and I called the
writer in and she sat for that last
moment where Daryl points a gun and says
I'm sorry
and looks him in the eye and I looked at
the writer she was bawling her eyes out
and I was like that was easy
damn I should do this all the time no it
was actually I was terrified
I think Ike invited and confided in Andy
link and then I was literally terrified
but starting next the beginning of
August I start my 18th episode
so if you really think about it I've
directed over an entire season of The
Walking Dead so cool that's beautiful
well greg we got to talk about effects
we got a bunch of Walking Dead fans here
we have a bunch of special-effects fans
yeah and you're one of the Masters and
this is the great thing about comic-con
is that they get to hear from masters
such as yourself how do you keep things
fresh and interesting when you're doing
new designs for zombies for walkers
you've been doing this for decades and
decades how do you keep it fresh for
yourself well I could tell you one thing
someone just asked me this I still love
I still love what I do
yeah and that's one of the things that
the Walking Dead really strives in
succeeds in those actors show up every
single day like it's their first day on
set I'm a fan of course so when we come
up with stuff it'll either be like a
cool homage to some other great George
Romero movie or some other cool zombie
movie or it'll just be pushing ourselves
you know every every good artist wants
to push themselves and wants to break
free of of
any sort of stumbling blocks and in with
the Walking Dead it's given me this
great opportunity every season to sort
of reexamine what we do and how we do it
I've had the same five makeup effects
guys on the show with me all seven years
and we did it we did a walker I don't
know if any of you guys saw the panel
yesterday or or you see my Instagram but
we started posting some walkers just
some first look zombies and we did one
on Wednesday
it was just horribly bloated just like
teeth were missing hideous and
disgusting
and we took a really skinny stunt guy
and we built him up and it's like we
should just try why do we have to do is
just build it and make it look cool and
every single guy on micro Kevin Weisser
did the makeup and they were like this
is my favorite zombie we've ever done
like they're still excited about it so
bringing that enthusiasm bringing that
dedication to it and I will honestly say
you guys you guys bring a lot of that
because this season seven which has been
unbelievably challenging from the first
episode which of course I can't talk
about so don't ask me I already told him
backstage what can I not ask anyway
thanks guys this be great I'll see you I
will tell you a very funny blooper
though so season 7 episode 1 which you
guys will see in October it was intense
man and the actors the actors really
went to some insane places so the last
night of shooting we had two cameras
rolling and I got on my knees and I gave
Rick Grimes the bat and I let him hit me
with the bat it was the happiest I've
ever seen him in seven years and it hurt
we had a rubber bat with a blood bag in
it he didn't pull back he were no more
and I even said you know it's like a
breakaway bottle you got to kind of pull
it back anyway yeah yeah yeah we're but
it was just you know you hear about
these directors who they want to put
themselves in the same place that the
actors are gone or going and yeah that
episode was intense so at the end I'm
like all right you know what guys I know
I want to put everybody through you get
a free shot you get one and I got on my
knees with lucio right there and I'm
like all right and we filmed it so I
have footage of it so of course I said
if we really wanted to torture people we
could have just been oh you want to
he kills and then just show the clip of
me but yeah it's it's been amazing and
and you know it's fun just coming up
with great stuff and the writers come up
with some really fun gags and you know
we don't want the the audience to see
the same zombie makeup season after
season so yeah we push ourselves to come
up with like oh maybe there's a guy
who's trapped in a sewer or maybe there
was a guy you know so we actually use
the storylines to push forward our
design sense and it works great well
since you brought up that ending yes I
kind of want to go there because that
frustrated a lot of people like you were
there making that choice like was there
how was the conversation about making
the choice of not seeing who he hit you
know it's a struggle or was it no it has
no we had a discussion about it but
honestly of the 20 million people that
watch the show
the ones that get angry because they
care yeah they're just loud and louder
than most of the people who just enjoy
the show and they're like I want to go
on this ride I like going on that ride
that's the right I mean I love Game of
Thrones man and I'm on it and I I don't
ever remember like yelling at my TV I
was just like this is amazing and I
can't wait to see what happens so you
know it it's all about the story yeah
what happens in the first episode
propels the surviving characters into an
entirely different place and that's what
the season is about that's exciting you
have to start there if you would have
started at the end of last season you
would have picked up sort of halfway in
the middle of a sentence and it would
have felt sure it would have felt
awkward so it's it's something that I
believed in yeah
and knowing how that moment affects
every surviving character and you know
what I love about did you guys see the
trailer yesterday for Walking Dead
pretty pretty fun we intended the
trailer to feel like a Star Wars trailer
where it's introducing the new worlds we
have the sanctuary and we have hilltop
and we have the Kingdom
and all of a sudden what you're
realizing what Rick realized at the end
of the last season which is the world
was way bigger than he imagined and he
has zero control
I think what's gut-wrenching about that
moment is it's the first time and this
is the note that I gave Andy when I was
directing that scene this is the first
time we've ever seen Rick Grimes scared
he is actually feeling fear and he's
never felt that before so you have to
feel that and so for this season if you
thought that he hit rock bottom it's
he's got further to go and watching
watching these people go there in the
first episode so we really wanted to
sell season seven on the promise of this
bigger world this larger world good guys
bad guys not so bad guys and it's for me
it's exciting because it's a new
territory yeah and and we're excited
that you know there was a little bit of
reaction to that moment but truthfully
oh we can have two weeks later it was
all gone and people that were vocal
about it kind of went you know it's a
really good episode and my pissed I have
to wait yeah but that's okay I'll see
what happens we're just going off of all
those great new elements you just
mentioned they're going to be introduced
in the new season I know we've talked
about this before the the art of
adaptation is is such a fascinating
thing to look at what kind of
conversations do you guys have what do
you pick and choose to adapt faithfully
or to change up from the comic books
from the source material because you
have that fantastic source material what
kind what are those types of
conversations like well it's interesting
because you have the iconic moments but
you also you also have to figure that
that everybody here probably has read
the comic book and sort of has this an
idea of where the comic book is going
but the truth is we want the show to
feel like its own entity in its own
animal so we will take iconic moment so
we might tweak them a little bit or or
just adjust them you know like
Herschel's death in the TV show was
tyreese's death in the comic right you
know every once in a while right we'll
sort of switch things
but we don't want people to read the
comic book to feel like oh we're just
getting a panel by panel adaptation
either and I've done that a couple
episodes that I directed the mid-season
premiere last year no way out which was
when the zombie the giant zombie attack
in Alexandria and Daryl blows everybody
up with the with the rocket launcher was
fun by the way but you know we had the
moment where Carl got shot in the eye
and where Jesse's killed that we
recreated those moments because those
were iconic moments and in the comic
book but then you know we we spend some
other things so we we are very conscious
about that but you know I mean as you
saw in the trailer we get to see Ezekiel
we could see Shiva that was an episode
that I directed so I got to sort of
introduce Khary Payton into the world
and the funniest thing is he fluted
Georgia and we had dinner and he got the
part but you know you have to sign all
this paperwork like you can't talk about
it so he was like I've can't
I've talked for six weeks about it he
literally exploded at dinner because he
was so excited about the character and
his ideas and what he wanted to do but
he was sitting in Los Angeles like I
can't say anything to anybody about what
I'm doing yeah so we were excited
yesterday because now we got to announce
it and everybody sees him and and it's
fun man it's it's it's challenging and
it's crazy and it's rough and the shoot
it gets harder every year never gets
easier on the show but do you have a
favorite character
I love Glenn I do I mean I put that
small childhood there loves pan I'll
tell you though I you know I was there
like on day one I've been with all of
these people our first day of shooting
Jon Bernthal and and Andy Lincoln were
in the in the cop car the first day that
we shot was Steven you know I was there
and even I had a talk about this the
other night I'm like dude there's like
three people on the planet that can say
they were there in the moment that Glenn
runs down the street and leads Rick into
the back alley in episode 1 episode 2
and I just I love who he is and I love
his character I love what
would Stephen does with him yeah so I
would always you know I mean I love Andy
and I love Norman and Jeffrey Dean
Morgan is astounding but yeah I think
Glenn has always been the character that
I've kind of respond I love the tune we
have actually had a segment on our show
called is Glenn dead yet I know yeah and
we are keep playing that season next
keep doing it for as long as we possibly
can
oh man so you guys had a conversation of
the night was this a filming recently or
was it like not on Saturday you guys saw
what he just did there so she was
already taking up to when he let Rick
have the first hit yeah okay all right
clues Chloe if you would have listened
when I said last night yeah we're at
comic-con thank you so clearly social
visit great not on set fantastic great
you know here's a here's a here's the
thing that I love about Walking Dead
we've heard the news that there are
plans to continue this story this epic
story for as long as possible and we've
had this conversation from a
storytelling standpoint and from a
special-effects standpoint have you guys
had conversations about what these
zombies and walkers are going to look
like five ten fifteen seasons from now
is there has every conversation do you
think there should be an end because
I've heard names like we want the show
to go on forever like what are you
thinking of feelings on I understand
both camps you know I it for me it's
intriguing because sure we have those
conversations that how long do you think
it'll go we're still I feel like we're
still scratching the surface really you
know the introduction of these new
worlds in season seven with negan and
all the people that come with him at the
sanctuary and the kingdom it's to me I
feel like we got a lot of story there
yeah in terms of the walkers you know
the one the one thing Scott Gimple and I
talk about very often is the anatomy of
it you know I mean I was pre-med before
I got into special effect that's awesome
so one of the things I will attribute to
the realism of our work is the fact that
I was going to be a doctor and then one
day I went hey so I got a call from
George Romero and
he said hey you want to come have lunch
with me I grew up in boy let me back up
right so here's I saw a guy he's mouches
at the floor so I feel like I'm tobacco
I grew up in Pittsburgh and I my uncle
was an actor and he was in the crazies
he played the deputy in the crazies in
like 72 or something so I became friends
with George and visited a bunch of his
sets when I was like 14 15 years old and
went to the Monroeville Mall when
they're shooting Dawn of the Dead and
visited the set of Creepshow and on the
set of Creepshow he said hey man do you
want a job like as a production
assistant and he dropped out of school I
mean oh hold that thought
okay um no but I I said you know let me
I'm just about to go away to college and
I'm premed thank you very much yeah and
then three years later Day of the Dead
gets a green light so I Drive downtown
to have lunch with George and he was a
managed to have some news you know we
got a green light on day the dead do you
want a job and my brain went right back
like three years earlier when I said no
to Creepshow and I went yes and then I
had to drive home and tell my folks hey
I'm gonna to make her take a semester
off of school I'm gonna work on this
movie yeah and and I'll go back in
December and I'll finish yeah still
haven't gone like I think my clothes are
still in my dorm room at Westminster
College with my books I just haven't
gone to get them yet I have a doctorate
by now for all of your anatomical you
think right yeah somebody come on guys
give him an come on guys doctorate
making a witch I heard you're giving me
one you're at you're speaking that
timely correct you're the special makeup
artists supervisor for Boogie Nights
does that mean you did the thing I hope
you did of course yes we have young
people here who sighs we have we have
your being done a front row of kids
right now
so I said and eloquently they're looking
at us like please explain what that
means okay I'm not gonna do it yeah look
subway he knows no he's not look
sometimes in Hollywood
all right good mom well we're hoping
that by the time this is over he still
doesn't know
I'm so sorry for about what's about to
happen mom Greg Greg made a fake peepee
for a movie okay this kid he's like yeah
I've seen Boogie Nights okay great so
yeah I haven't seen it we have a lot of
range of script but I'll get to it we
got a lot of questions about this fake
peepee is it easier to make a pee-pee
that looks natural like a like a human
peepee instead of something being
wrecked ripped apart by zombies
how many prosthetic peepees did you make
for the movie where are all of the fake
pee pees now did you have a sense when
working on the pee pee that it would
occupy such a central is it really say
pee pee on account for me never that
could be that car it does it I had to
work on the fly hey kids I apologize but
okay number one yes we have sorry mom we
had there were you know there's a lot of
photos available so we had reference and
we had to do several camera tests with
Heather Graham and the camera tests were
you know l-shaped or you know whatever
direction you needed it's a point we
have tested it sure and in terms of
where they are Howard Stern has one
really I went on the Howard Stern Show
and he was going on and on about Boogie
Nights and so we presented him with one
oh there's there's another one in the
Smiths ironically no good idea Yeah
right next to Archie Bunker's chair and
the enterprise that would be like an
alien ship flying popular culture that's
right ironically there there's one under
the front seat of my car because I I had
one made and I had it shipped down to
give to Andy and Norman because they
wanted to pull some pranks yeah a prank
and I realized like three months ago
that it's still in the box so if I get
pulled over in Georgia I not quite sure
how low you step out of the car so if
you step out of the vehicle services do
you have any hidden weapons in the car
do you have any well no you also did Gus
Frings blown up faced and Breaking Bad
yeah which is so cool because I think so
many people thought that was digital but
that was real
some applause oh we thank you now that
was Gus Springs right cheek just
apologized and applauded no you know it
Walking Dead opened some doors for us
yeah on Breaking Bad Michelle Maclaren
who directed on season one called me and
said hey man so I am directing on
Breaking Bad and we'd love for you to
come in and do a couple gags I hated to
admit I hadn't seen the show yet yeah
and the first episode we did was the box
cutter episode where Gus cuts the guy's
throat and then Jesse and wants to put
him in the the barrel of acid and melt
him so so that I they're like we can't
tell you who it is and I'm like I don't
know I haven't seen the show you got to
tell me any names I wouldn't know so it
was interesting because you know we were
we were dealing with Vince and it was
like okay well we want to slash the
throat and we want some blood to gurgle
over and we want another blood to spray
so that we can hit Aaron and Brian with
the blood spray so we so it's
interesting if you really think about
these are the conversations I love
having at restaurants where you're
sitting next to somebody okay so if you
cut his throat where do you want the
blood to go there's old there's an old
lady at the next table going so we put
one tube underneath the prosthetic we
had done it on inglourious basterds as
well so what happens if you have the
prosthetic and you put the slit high and
the tubes underneath so when the blood
fills up and then flows over so it kind
of bubbles out so we had one tube there
then we had a second tube that had a
little arterial spray so we had two
different ways of pumping the blood so
at from that moment on it was like every
gag they had they called us and cool so
for that particular thing for that for a
gustas gag you know he came in we did it
giancarlo came in we did a head cast of
him we sculpted the prosthetic and then
we sculpted a fake head so we could
actually get the death so the prosthetic
was on his
but anything that went deeper than his
real skin visual-effects
composited like chunks of his cheekbone
and blown away so it was a combination
to what you guys built what we built and
then visual fix took that and of course
they did a they did at any panel and
Vince we we put Gus's head on the table
during the panel so of course Vince has
one and Bryan Cranston's like how do I
get one of those so I've made like Aaron
Paul has one Vince has one and and of
course Giancarlo has one I called I
called Sony because I wanted the
Wardrobe because I wanted it standing in
the front door of K&B so when like the
FedEx guy walks in there's just Emily
well there's so many things to talk
about I wouldn't Terry have more time
you've done so many films with Tarantino
and I know
Tarantino fans in the house right I just
want to hear a little like what is that
like and does that you've worked with so
many great directors like has that you
know how what have you borrowed and what
have you learned
look that's a great thank you that's an
amazing question because I feel like
then you didn't use the word PP I think
I've had the greatest film school
experience in the world working
alongside Wes Craven and John Carpenter
and George Romero and Robert Rodriguez
and Frank Darabont Spielberg in Quentin
and I've taken something away from every
one of them and as a director I feel
like I've been able to sort of mold my
style based on what I've learned you
know as an example in Inglourious
Basterds in the la Louisiane when
they're doing the three versus the three
and the big shootout so we spent four
weeks shooting that scene and Quentin
rehearsed it with the actors and and
then you'll you'll do something else
where you shoot it in two days so I feel
like the what I've learned from all of
these directors and what I've taken away
from them has been is shaped Who I am as
a filmmaker and that's tremendously
exciting to me and the fact that now for
me to be able to give back to future
these guys special effects or moviemaker
whatever they're gonna be they've been
taking about being inspired now by the
stuff that I do just like I was inspired
by the stuff they do so to me that's the
greatest compliment when somebody comes
up says I want to do makeup I really
feel the walking dead has sort of
reinvigorated practical makeup effects
to a whole new generation that hadn't
seen it you don't you never saw anything
like that on cam he's seven years ago
yeah so that makes me proud you know so
talking about inspirations I think I got
to know this this is this is a really
really great question what movie do you
think has the all-time best special
effects what kind of stuff were you
inspired by they wanted you to get into
the business
all right well best special effects I
would say John Carpenter's The Thing
rabo teen still to this day and it's
interesting because I've worked with
John quite a bit yeah and and he talked
about the making of that movie in and
how at the time people had such a
negative reaction to the film because
they felt it was so gory and people were
nauseate
the blood and and now it's literally a
masterclass in suspense in in filmmaking
in terms of my favorite movies jaws and
Dawn of the Dead fight each other
zombie versus shark like every single
day and then one day jaws wins and the
next day the original Dawn of the Dead
of course so those are the movies that
when I saw them in the theater I just
like my world was different when I
walked out I would I remember standing
in line to see jaws and in the lobby
they had like the lobby cards and it was
once a eerie big jaws fan right huge I
heard you have a Bruce shark I have yes
we have we recreated Bruce with the head
for jaws fest for the 20th anniversary
and I worked with Roy Arbogast and Joe
Alves who were the production designer
and the effects guy and they gave me
some of the teeth and I put the real
teeth in it and I still have this
fantasy of putting the head on my
swimming pool with a fountain of red
just shooting out of the mouth but then
I figure like after 30 seconds the
entire pool will be red and
we'll be over but I haven't figured it
out yet but you know it's to me it's
it's and it's a little bit of a bummer
today I will say because it's so easy to
know find out how they did it yeah you
can go online and you go type in how do
they do that and they'll be like 50
articles but when I was a kid when the
Exorcist came out there wasn't an art
you couldn't look up like how do they
transform Linda Blair into this you just
watched the movie when they really did
that like that woman they must have gone
like you know casting audition for
possessed girls and you sure no bomb it
but now nowadays because that
information is out there it's a blessing
and a curse it's a blessing because it's
fascinating you want to learn how they
do it yeah but it takes the magic away
and you know for me practical effects is
so critical you know with visual effects
it's a it's a fantastic medium and a
great art form I always feel like
there's a perfect meld between the two
and you use the tool as needed and
that's my job is to go to the director
and say we can build this and then if
you need it to run across the room and
rip through all those string lights
you'd do a CG character and then we'll
pick it up there and we'll pick it up
there but I move ease they still inspire
me and I still love them and and I have
I bought a house in Georgia and every
time somebody comes over I the attic was
empty when I bought it and I was like
this could either be a great haunted
house or a little movie theater so I put
a little movie theater out there and
every time somebody comes hey whoa check
it out and I just put jaws on there like
have you not seen John my god look it's
jaw yeah well you've inspired a lot of
people and I'm so grateful you made time
for here yeah and this crowd how about a
round of applause for Greg Nicotero
kotero thanks guys someday we got to
figure out a way the screen junkies come
see your shop and see the amazing things
you have we don't see go see Suicide
Squad we did okay David Ayer I worked
with Jerome Chen on the spider amazing
spider-man 2
and it was a fascinating experience
because we had to design the character
before we had the actor Dave Grasso John
Wetton myself we designed this amazing
character you know we didn't want him to
be crocodile faced with yeah the
humanity of Adewale in there and
versions like were you processing
because it is a hard character what not
that many ironic I mean the director
David knew very much what direction he
wanted to go and I was happy that we
sort of got there so we did our research
prior to when they cast him so by the
time we got addy it was the beginning of
March and we started shooting like the
end of April so we turned it around
quick so work because I'm fascinated
that so David Ayer has his vision you
have a vision like how does that work he
does you do you then pitch to hear some
takes were thinking babies notes yeah
and and it was it was a very good
experience because you you what your job
is to translate what the director once
and then keep your artistic vision in
there as well so like the idea of eyes
you know we didn't we didn't want
contact lenses in him because he was
completely covered he at dentures full
head full torso I mean Chris Nelson
applied the makeup and Sean sands I'm up
in Toronto and it was it was intense and
it was just very so we didn't want to
have to put contact lenses in them but I
remember during filming there like we
kind of like Addie's eyes in there and
we sort of pitched to them guys I know
but just take it one level further put a
little CG little dictating membrane and
they're so cool so I haven't seen the
movie yet but obviously I've seen a lot
of promos I'm really excited about it
yeah can't be more proud of David and
and and everybody involved so awesome so
go check that out I'll go BRR Suicide
Squad the Saugus thanks guys gentleman
Greg Nicotero thank you so much for
watching will he have some more fun
stuff stay tuned but war last time thank
you so much Greg
thanks again to sponsor t-mobile with
double the LTE coverage hit your screen
junkies fix in more places to watch our
previous show click to the left and to
view everything else from screen junkie
central click to the right